Frank I sold our friend from the New
York Daily News joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show what's up Frank hey Rick
how are you today
so did you speak to uh porzingis his
brother yesterday did you do your
newspaper did who yes i spoke some late
yesterday afternoon and you know well
he's not too surprised a little upset
you know I mean I think they figured
that there was a chance that this could
be out there they don't think it's going
to happen they think the Knicks would
kind of be crazy to do it but at this
point nothing surprises them in terms of
you know what the Knicks could do and I
think once Chris Epps did not show a
projected meeting and they kind of all
bets were off at that point and it still
haven't spoken in chips then which
absolutely makes no sense so everything
is on the table I tend to doubt that
he's going to get traded why would you
trade it you're trying to rebuild a
needs a 21 year old kid that you already
have two years under your belt trying to
develop so that makes no sense
straight up unless they figure that he's
the only possible piece that could bring
in absolutely anything in kickstart
something that was 80 and 166 over the
last few seasons Frank
I think it's sheer madness and the thing
that I have a problem with the most is
it is an admission that the last three
years was a failure and the person who
failed at it feels completely
comfortable to go ahead and hit a reset
button which means it's the problem from
up top that's my the way reading of it
Frank you tell me how it's landing there
in the metropolitan area I I think
that's how a lot of people look at it
because how can you say you're
rebuilding and you're going to trade
this guy then you go start all over and
if you're going to get just draft picks
that's the great unknown and you don't
know but I was just looking back at like
the 2012 draft yet Anthony Davis was
first yo Michael kidd-gilchrist was
second look how he's 10th at Bradley
Beal is a good player dion Waiters the
sport Tristan Thompson [ __ ] but that's a
role player dad you know Terrence Ross
was the 8th pick Austin Rivers was the
10th together those are good players you
know you laugh a guy like Chris had
porzingis porzingis was in the draft
today I would suggest you he would be
the number one pick once again he's only
21 years old so I can't maybe Phil
Jackson is doing this as a way to shake
porzingis up a little bit and say oh you
think that you you can call us out and
not show up at a meeting and we're going
to get nervous well guess what
is always the possibility that we can
trade you so it seems to be silly I
think you'd want to maintain a good
relationship with your best player but
then again Phil did not maintain a great
relationship with Carmelo Anthony but we
say that all turned out that seems to be
going down the same road as porzingis at
some point the Knicks have to end this
nonsense that they either fly over the
Latvia will bring him back here and talk
down because why would you know we know
how important one player is on a
basketball team it could be the
difference maker and why have a bad
relationship with this guy who's
supposed to be the star of your team
well so what is the Carmelo situation
because I imagine that could that's one
star player obviously in his 30s that we
haven't heard being bandied about when
you've got the Paul George's and Jimmy
Butler's of the world being thrown out
there that would be certainly a name
that would garner some interest and
certainly shake things up in this super
team era of everybody trying to combine
forces to get in the Warriors district
Frank yeah I think that makes the most
sense and I don't know what kind of deal
with it I can't imagine equipment
heavily was going to trade Kevin Love a
criminal Anthony that would make no
sense but if I were a Cleveland maybe
you're hoping that carmella could work
on some kind of buyout and you could
sign and so obviously a really low
number to bring them and maybe there's
some kind of trach and you get a third
team in violating at this stage Carmelo
knows that his future is not in New York
if you want if he wants to kind of
change the narrative on the last part of
this career he's going to need to move
on and if you goes to Cleveland and ends
up with LeBron at least for one year
that's a good thing and who's to say
that the two of them don't get up and
leave and go to LA the next summer which
would also be on the table so I think at
this point
Carmelo knows that its future in New
York is over it's not going to happen
even though he is on the contract and
even though he still has a final say on
whether or not he gets traded to a
certain team but also the Clippers would
be involved as well so I expect
something to happen probably in July
maybe even in August but I think
something's going to happen people
training camp with Carmel Frank I solo
the daily news joining us here and what
is going on in Cleveland Chauncey
Billups reportedly having a second
conversation with Dan Gilbert today
Charles oakley's best friend and Dan
Gilbert what what is the scoop right
there because LeBrons future
short and long-term can depend upon how
that relationship Virgins should it have
to at all take place and if I'm Chauncey
Billups and I do get that job I think
the main thing is you're trying to do
everything you can to get LeBron James
on the contract for at least two more
years after the seat because it's going
to be a championship team you have to
have LeBron James there and Chauncey's
wanted something like this he's
obviously a very bright guy you know he
knows the league but it's also a
different job when you're becoming a
general manager he's going to walk into
a complicated situation yes you have
LeBron there but they do need to make
some moves to close the gap with the
Golden State Warriors and there's always
like minor moves it's not - you know we
all know that yeah it's great that
LeBron James on our team it's about
making those minor moves that really
sometimes you know make the whole team
come together than to make you a
championship team so yes on the winner
is walking into a great situation who
gets the job because we're bran is there
but you know he's got a long road ahead
of them because you want to be the
general manager of the team that loses
LeBron James for a second time which
would certainly be in play next summer
and then we you hear conversations like
DeAndre Jordan being coughed up or
offered up by the Clippers for the
number four overall selection and then
you hear draft choices hopefully being
packaged together by other teams for
Paul George what is based on your
conversations and hearing getting ready
for the draft that's going down in
Brooklyn tomorrow night Frank about how
general managers view star players and
the possibility of drafting one and how
that actually is viewed and building a
team right now in the superteam era well
I mean that's the thing you know however
if you look at mostly scenes in the East
End in Boston it's a perfect example
they're kind of like right there they're
close to being you know a top legitimate
championship contender I get it they
made it to the conference file but I
don't think we thought they were going
to be Cleveland or Golden State it's
almost like these guys are waiting you
know for LeBron I get a little bit older
maybe waiting for the Golden State
Warriors Neal for them to break up which
might not happen for two years right now
so it seems like the rest of the league
is rebuilding and kind of waiting for
Cleveland and for Golden State for those
two teams to kind of run their
course and there's so much movement at
this time of year and for whatever
reason there seems like there seems to
be more activity than usual because I
think a lot of teams don't want to take
on crazy contracts I think a lot of
teams are trying to rebuild and taking
the much longer approach in terms of
building identities of what's going on
right now with Cleveland and with the
Golden State Warriors and the thing
about the porzingis stuff that really
got me was hearing that the Celtics were
calling for him there's no way right
that if porzingis goes that he would be
shipped and put and put into a green
uniform for for him to lead the celtics
to hang another banner and come into
Madison Square Garden year after year I
mean would they really do something like
that Frank know what I question a lot of
things that tell Jackson doesn't mean I
think most people do but Phil Jackson is
an old-school Knick played under ed
Holtzman everyone knows about the
rivalry between the Knicks and the
Celtics red Holzman Red Auerbach I could
not imagine that Phil Jackson is sitting
down entertaining making a deal with the
Boston Celtics plus he also experienced
the Boston Celtics as the coach of the
Lakers having played them in the finals
twice and losing to them once and other
sheelane his last championship so I
don't buy it
I can't imagine he's going to trade the
old-school Knicks Phil Jackson is going
to be trading his best player to the
Boston Celtics regardless of what a
night be getting back I just don't
believe and what's the surprise for
tomorrow night
what do you think the best chance for a
surprise for tomorrow night's Draft
would be what maybe something involving
Paul George maybe some type of freeway
that involved the Phoenix Suns and pix
being moved maybe that's where the draft
will start also with Boston because
remember you know they they had marquel
bulbs they didn't want them so that's
gonna pick third and they're probably
choosing right now between Josh Jackson
and Jason Batum I would go with the
offensive player Tatum was a big-time
shooter there's been some talk to go
with Josh Jackson he's kind of he's a
very good defensive player big athlete
but not a great shooter so there could
be some intrigue at three but I think
Paul chewers that would be the big one
will he get traded tomorrow and if that
happened that would obviously be the big
story of the dress and I'm probably what
why isn't the iron Fox being thrown out
there just because of situations Celtics
didn't need
fault so why would they go with Fox and
then you got the Phoenix Suns they're
not they don't need him I guess
technically quote-unquote and the Kings
I guess would so he we had fifth overall
is that a need situation right now why
Fox Hannity mentioning absolutely and I
don't think Fox is going to go below
five that that seems to be the case and
he seems to be the most polished in a
lot of different ways when you do see in
play when you do see him off the court
so he's a big-time player I'm sure the
Knicks would love to get him a date but
I think he'll be there at five the big
one ll be Josh Jackson the word was that
the Celtics like them at one now maybe
then excuse them to take them at three
ago fake Batum so that you know the NBA
I gotta give them credit
you know the playoffs weren't that great
but thus far the offseason is certainly
generating a comedy there's no doubt and
we talked about this I guess last one
for you Frank Isola The Daily News that
you know I was highly critical of the
lack of competition and the super team
arrow did not really lead too much in
the playoffs at all but perhaps it has
caused teams to get more aggressive and
creative knowing the big gap and the
difference between them and the Warriors
and what the Warriors did to a 73 win
team to improve it that that might be
now contagious what do you think of that
yeah III think there's some truth to
that but I think it's also the material
for fans when you go into an NBA season
thinking well it's really going to
probably be the Warriors and the
Cleveland Cavaliers again you don't
really have that much of a chance and it
really doesn't happen in any other sport
I mean look at Nashville making the
Stanley Cup Finals I get that the
Patriots are always good but that's a
single elimination tournament that
they're and they've actually lost home
playoff games before in baseball
obviously is a crapshoot as well it
seems to be like the one sport where
last July it's funny on Kevin Durant's
mother after the you know he won the
championship but saying oh you know a
lot of people if you do it well actually
I think just about everyone thought but
the Cong say lawyers were going to win
the championship after he decided to go
there over July 4th weekend it's a
problem that the league has from a
competitive standpoint that the ratings
are good so I don't think they care
about that but the next scene it'll be
interesting that I think really now fans
get the sense it's almost like a two
teen league as of right now maybe things
will change
coming with ya man maybe just maybe
let's let's let's just extrapolate this
out Frank just maybe porzingis stays put
so does Carmelo uh Phil strikes gold
again with the 8th overall pick dressed
another purple unicorn and Derrick Rose
stays to create the super team he said
that he had created just by merely
showing up last year
yes they ranked they would be a super
team in name only but guess what it's
the results that make you a super cut
your names on the back of the jersey
forgot about that
that's right they did do take care Frank
take care
you got his Frank I so love the daily
news so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
download our app please just give it's a
memory thing just delete other apps you
don't need those apps this app the Rich
Eisen show up you need that